[Musique]
laissez-vous d'employés il est
exactement
20h43 c'est l'anniversaire de camille
camille combal qu'on appelle kamouche
exactement 27 ans boca mouche
il ya deux cadeaux ou la vidéo d'une
star ou la vidéo d'une cithare bien
qu'ici ou un voyage à los angeles c'est
ton anniversaire c'est maintenant tu
prends la décision 3-2 un top à et vas-y
envoie-t-on escalopes bien est ce tu
ferais tu veux alors moi je ne sais pas
ce qu'il ya dans les boîtes je ne sais
pas ce qu'est dans les boîtes j'ai menti
je sais ce cadre y aller je m'excuse
mais je reste sur ma décision je reste
je serai prêt je m'en vouloir tu gardes
la boîte 3 non je suis la 2g vedette
non tu gagnes la boîte 3 oui je garde la
tranche garde là deux sentiments la
dette
je peux pas te dire moi je prend la 2
non non on gère la 3 et avait dit frère
ma gueule embrouillé et sans la 3d où
elle était tombée bas 3 allez on n'en
parle plus la 3 3 n'est pas la tête de
suspense je sais que tu veux faire je
vais te montrer d'abord la vidéo du gard
voilà oui et je te dirai après si
c'était ton cadeau aussi tu parles los
angeles ont garni un gars qui t'a donné
quitus était bon anniversaire et voit la
petite vidéo du jour pour coter de
joyeux anniversaire à toi camille
camille combal donc joyeux anniversaire
à toi qu'est la famille
telle est la phrase est allée chambre à
cap-chat aux lilas tout ton plateau
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup également la doublette toutes
les équipes de foot et paris gare de
lyon dans ta près je mets toutes ces
cités caen rennes avec mon ami mais
merci merci a dit adila lorsque c'est ça
ton cadeau et c'est terminé ça me ferait
savoir déjà très plaisir tu as tu appris
la vôtre j'ai pris la boîte j'ai pris
l'armé offensive l'a3 la boîte 3 camille
combal
je vérifie comme camille combal monde
chéri bas beaucoup de chance car mon
camille combal jérôme revon je peux te
le faire sur cette caméra mon chéri
merci mon bébé camille combal tu pars
revoir la vidéo ta star chez toi non
touche passage le voyage los angeles les
dégoûte fait un beau voyage aux indes et
on va vérifier quand même on va vérifier
quand même mais en plus je le savais je
n'ai pas écouté les potes mais je te
l'offre quand même la ville de barr
c'est là sans fil de la compagnie de mme
amara vendredi 22 septembre et pour
chaque disque vendu les chéris 1 euro
est reversé à l'association les anges de
la rue qui s'occupe de personnes en
difficulté c'est très important parce
que l'hiver arrive et il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se baladent renchérit je sais
que je t'aime tu pars avec cette boîte
est bien sûr que tu pars à los angeles
c'est un puzzle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
normal
c'est comme ça merci applaudissements
pour qu'elle tombe
n'osant pas tu seras là bien sûr demain
mais tu pars ce week end ce futur mais
je crois que je n'ai pas loupé quoi tu
parle vraiment los angeles nous enverra
des snacks des trucs on attend de vous
avoir connu